Florida's rainy season is ramping up and
so is the threat of mosquitos carrying
the Zika virus more than 5,000 people in
the US have reported having Zika since
last year most caught it overseas but
nearly all 224 locally transmitted cases
in 2016 happened in Florida
a recent study reports the virus likely
began spreading last year in Florida
months earlier than the first confirmed
locally transmitted case miami-dade
County is working to control mosquito
populations and reduce Zika infections
the virus is especially dangerous for
pregnant women and well Bojorquez is on
Miami South Beach which was declared as
ecozone last year man well good morning
good morning the unofficial start of
summer means a renewed push for Zika
awareness the CDC says it's still seeing
up to 40 new pregnant women with Zika
every week nationwide the good news here
in Florida is the Department of Health
says there have been no new locally
transmitted cases since March but Miami
officials are not letting their guard
down 38 year-old Jessica Flores was
understandably nervous as she prepared
to give birth in January she contracted
Zika when she was seven weeks pregnant
at the height of Florida Zika scare when
daughter Daniela was born she looked and
sounded like any healthy newborn no
visible symptoms or defects nothing book
and her father gave prayerful thanks
right on the delivery room floor yes
food and Danny now still healthy at four
months Daniela continues to be measured
and monitored for developmental issues
beyond microcephaly she appears to be
every bit a good healthy beautiful baby
girl but what are the risks for her
going forward so part of the reason we
continue to bring her baby back for
check-ups is that we want to see our the
back of the eyes developing normally
is the baby hearing normally dr.
Christine Currie heads the Zika response
team at the University of Miami
she says one in ten babies born to Zika
positive moms have some sort of serious
birth defect
but she worries that many are not
receiving critical follow-up care we
lose about a quarter of those families
after delivery where they go back to
their community hospital their community
pediatrician and they don't stay engaged
with our care and that means we don't
have any data on what's happening with
them in South Florida crews are hitting
the ground early using larvacide to kill
mosquitoes before they hatch
last season miami-dade county air
dropped the controversial pesticide
naled in several citizens and residents
protested hey hey we don't want no spray
miami-dade Mayor Carlos Gimenez hopes it
won't come to that again this year
they've beefed up the mosquito control
budget and are pushing community
awareness if you don't plan on having
you know a child etc it's still it's
your personal responsibility to make
sure you don't become a transmitter to
somebody that does that's where our
message is here you know all of us have
to take care of all of us but not every
homeowner is up to speed you thought it
was gone that's going give wow so make a
gun it's not gone yes I did only be in
si mi siento Finley
Jessica Flores told us she went public
to promote awareness so that other
pregnant women can avoid the stress and
anxiety
she suffered is this just something we
now have to live with is Zika ever gonna
go away we live in a time of Zika and
this is something that we are going to
deal with this season and maybe next
season ultimately until there's either
treatment vaccination or both this is
the world that we live in the Zika
vaccine is still in its second phase of
testing so it won't be available for
this season a recent report from
Stanford University suggested Zika can
be transmitted at a temperature of 84
degrees that is six degrees lower than
originally thought the high here in
Miami today is expected to be in the 90s
Dana ml Bojorquez Thank You Manuel